hey pedro yeah welcome to the show i'm
the main attraction
let's go up another one that's a double
oh
i might as well drill you both
you're not hitting like like pedro or
randy they're a little lost out you're
not touching pedro martinez i think it's
lenia
i think you could too for the record i
think
i can i know
i know i could do better than you though
he's getting tired you see him
he's done
that one no bueno ow hey all i got to do
is beat that guy it's this you have said
them don't i gotta beat that guy that's
all that's all i'm concerned about this
one
i was swinging this week where are you
he's been training for this okay so i'm
gonna turn you around when i get up
that's just bp
that's a good pitch
that's what i think of that pedro spend
on that
ump he's already complaining my time my
time
[Music]
what's this hey you want to clear the
benches we can clear the bathroom
[Laughter]
i guarantee you though yes sir good job
man number one got a double one
this guy
you think it out you're not gonna leg
out a squiffer yeah hey pedro's right
you dang here gotta hit it out mike why
do i go second
stay there pedro huh babe
sure
that was a good curveball that was a
good one yeah that was the best one more
pitch better hit it out now
it's my moment greg oh mike
okay
okay boy
not guys there what do you think pedro
two doubles
guy's there
that's two doubles
that was caught
why did you do this i just had the best
moment in my entire life you could say
that was cut we just video evidence i
don't know about that how do you get a
tape measure up pedro who won a football
player well center field compared to
left field but actually the sound off
the bat tells me he won
we're telling my sound now no because
you use that cast the villo out of the
bat
and you stock cash nerds are ruining
baseball big guys chocolate you've got
can we run the payback hey listen
you're hitting against an old goat
and you're talking you're pimping about
that
and i'm throwing you this nice bp
fastballs right there you
he doesn't know it yet
but i do have the deeply doing here you
were lucky i had my command today
[Music]
80. let's go
that's it arm's gone tommy john when you
get the medic in here
that's one turnover
that's gotta oh